[Music]
hi i'm elliot murphy i'm a postdoc
in the lab of dr nitin tandem in um
medical school in houston texas i study
the neural basis of language in
particular higher order syntax and
semantics
using integral recordings of
patients with refractory epilepsy
and today i'm going to be reviewing a
bunch of experiments that we've been
conducting over the last few years
trying to probe
language specific aspects of meaning
in particular contributions that
language makes to human meaning that
maybe some of the systems
like
attention visual perception maybe don't
contribute so aspects of human meaning
and representation that are potentially
either unique in organization and
structure um or at least more kind of
salient and present in everyday
human interactions than might be for
kind of non-linguistic faculties
so i'll be talking about um as i say
linguistic meaning in the brain and
there's quite a lot of
ways we can talk about meaning we can
talk about the meaning of life and the
meaning of chair the meaning of
cheesecake and but i'll be talking about
very basic elementary forms of meaning
that enter into
much more complex forms of
cognition planning and interpretation
and inference which are essential for
everyday human
function like communication and thinking
and planning and but also on the surface
seem quite simple but when you get to
the neural basis of these processes the
system itself becomes quite complex
and a lot of meaning turns out to be
linguistically structured as well which
is quite interesting
there are also forms of meaning that we
can affair
that are constrained by the ways that
our language faculty organizes sets of
words into larger structures
so for instance i've given you the
phrase here eat cheesecake that is a
verb phrase it's an event there is an
event of eating and the object of the
event is cheesecake
and
whenever two words are put together into
a phrase there seems to be an immediate
sense of asymmetry
words are not simply put together in a
kind of linear concatenated um
fashion there seems to be some sense of
asymmetry um arising from the
combination of two words so for instance
take a very obvious example
something like a blue car
when you make the phrase
blue car from the two words blue and car
you get a very simple phrase
and but notice something quite
interesting
a blue car is a car
which is blue
it's not a blue quality that has
a car related features right and it is
primarily a car and you're simply
describing it as blue
it's not as if there is a blue entity
out there and you just happen to be
describing it as exhibiting features
that
uh qualify it to be a car
so there seems to be a sense in which
combining the word blue and car doesn't
simply give you a kind of a
structure going on there there seems to
be a slight ace imagery there seems to
be a sense in which combining words
together gives you a kind of a sense of
meaning a kind of meaning to the phrase
that goes beyond the simple combination
of two words so it's not as if using
people put um two plus two together and
you get four it seems if you you you put
together two words that are in in
isolation have their own meaning but
when you put them together it kind of
yields a slightly different um
meaning that
the two words in isolation cannot
deliver so there are forms of meaning
that you can only really get if you put
multiple words together there are forms
of meaning that you can only generate if
you put larger structures and into a
kind of larger unit
and
so i'll be exploring uh three aspects of
meaning which due to a purely an
accident of human phenology they have
the same first letter uh combination
concreteness and coherence so i'm going
to be starting here with a combination
and putting two words together
in order to have higher order language
you need to be able to put two words
together if you can't do that then
you're really in trouble you have to at
least be able to put two words together
and then add another one and another one
another one to string a larger and
larger sentence together to construct
complex language if you can't do that
then you really don't have language
and so linguists have organized a
general have identified a general trait
which is the ability to construct
hierarchically organized structures in a
recursive fashion
of the kind i've mentioned here even
something simple like a blue car has a
kind of unique structure to it as i
mentioned it's not simply blue plus car
it's something a little bit different
there's a kind of unique
um asymmetry going on here
they've also identified a possible
mechanism the mechanism being the
computational procedure what linguists
called merge which simply takes elements
from the lexicon and forms a set it
forms structures and but the question of
neural basis has remained quite
obscure what exactly is the brain doing
when we put two things together into a
larger structure
and i'm going to review some
intracranial experiments that we've done
that have shown that there seems to be a
unique contribution to posterior
superior temporal surface
in the construction of basic phrases
above and beyond the construction of
lexical meaning so a phrasal meaning is
as i've mentioned very different from
lexical meaning so therefore there must
be some kind of brain mechanism that
identifies phrasal meaning as distinct
from individual word meaning
so in order to probe this um
we need to kind of address some of the
basic limitations of intercranial
recordings so some of the most
well-known challenges and limitations of
intracranial eeg is there is limited
cortical coverage
there's also natural variations in
anatomy and other kind of common
limitations so our lab has developed a
surface-based mix effects multi-level
analysis or sb mima which yields
topologically precise non-linear
registration
of the
electrodes on the surface of individual
patients and it generates surface
recording zones in standard space
and it allows you to plot um gamma
higher gamma signatures across cortex in
a kind of um in a way that shows local
cortical processing
so we're going to use that technique
to uh tap into a very simple paradigm we
gave patients two word phrases
and and these phrases either had a
pseudo word or did not have a pseudo
word in them so we gave them phrases
like red car and then the task was to
look at a picture of a red car and
identify whether or not the picture
matched the phrase so in this case you
can see that there was a red car and a
picture of red car and the patients had
to say yes or no
they simply press the button yes or no
um however we also gave them red bull
or bulge car where bulge is a pseudo
word with a pseudo word being
a sound that obeys english phrenology
but just doesn't have a meaning so it's
the kind of thing that could be
hypothetically a real word but for some
accidental phonology it just happens to
not have been assembled into a real
world and there's lots of pseudo words
you can imagine
but we do this to probe the processing
of real genuine meaning as opposed to
structures that and do not have any
actual lexical meaning so our electro
coverage was pretty generous uh pretty
pretty as you can see in the figure in
panel b
frontal temporal coverage is quite
considerable
and in response to
individual words when we did a word
versus suitable contrast we found
greater local cortical processing
indexed by broadband gamma activity from
70 to 150 hertz in and around psts and
pstg
and and you can see some example of
traces on the right there
so that's the response to individual
lexical meaning but then once you've
heard the first word there is a sense in
which your the patients are going to
anticipate what's coming next
so we know that when we construct
individual uh linguistic phrases
uh structure is built predictably in
anticipation of upcoming stimuli
and as well as recent psycholinguistic
work showing that these predictions are
widespread a widespread across all sizes
of phrases and clauses
and but the question for us is how does
the brain organize neural
representations to construct a noun
phrase regardless of what the noun is
so the patients know they're going to
hear in our phrase they know they're
going to hear something like red boat or
blue car
or brown bag
and but sometimes it doesn't really
matter what the
actual nominal is they know that they're
going to generate a structure some kind
of a two two-word structure
so the question for us is can we find a
signature of that anticipatory process
before the onset of the second word
but after they've heard a real word
so we compared
trials in which the patients had just
encountered a real word like red
and i've compared that to trials in
which they just encountered a pseudo-it
so obviously
you only anticipate a real nominal
phrase if you've just had an adjective a
real adjective because then the patient
knows that they're going to have a real
phrase whereas if they've just had a
pseudo word then they know that it's not
going to be a meaningful phrase because
it has a pseudo within it
so we look at lower frequency activity
around the alpha and beta range because
lower frequencies seem to organize
activity across larger portions of
cortex than local gamma activity so our
results seem to suggest as you can see
in the figure and panel a
that portions of ifg seem to maybe
provide top-down inferences about
syntactic slot building they seem to be
um
they show increased low frequency
activity in anticipation of a real noun
freeze so it's almost if they're
potentially gearing up or getting ready
and preparing a slot to be filled um in
order for
um regardless of whatever now happens to
be encountered
so with respect to actual compositional
effects we compared the responses at the
second word for phrases versus uh
non-phrases so red boat versus um the
two word phrases that contain
pseudowords
and we showed kind of a unique signature
again indexed by broadband gamma
activity
um across a narrow portion of posterior
superior temporal sulcus such that very
closely and neighboring electrodes coded
either for lexical meaning or phrasal
meaning
but not both in fact only three
electrodes coded for both phrasal and
electrical meaning so there's a sense in
which there are electrodes in pscs that
are uniquely sensitive not just to
lexical meaning as in the meaning of red
or the meaning of both but also to the
meaning of red though
and that's very kind of a uni again
a language specific trait the
sensitivity not just to the meaning of
red or the meaning of bo but to the
meaning of red bow
and of course indexing the uh
sensitivity to basic phrasal meaning is
the very starting point for a real
neurobiological
model of language
and so in fact there is a sense in which
this region that we've identified psts
might actually be you can kind of think
of it as the language region
in fact i kind of i like to think of it
as the language region um because all
the things that are
commonly discussed in the neurobiology
of language literature
and indeed are pertaining to aspects of
language and speech comprehension and
prediction and lexical access and so on
but really the core of language when you
think about it the core of language is
really this ability to put two things
together into a larger structure
and so this region seems to be uniquely
sensitive to that
in addition the
two reasons that i've already mentioned
psts and ifg showed significant
functional connectivity during phrase
composition relative to non-phrase
composition
so you can see in the panel c at the
bottom there that um the sites in pscs
the electrodes that were sensitive to
composition or they did show greater bga
responses to phrases
those were the electrodes that showed
increased functional connectivity with
ifg and not the other pscs electrodes
that did not show
effects of composition
so this is a potential sense in which
psts is potentially generating the
structure that is being inferred by the
two words and then either
shipping it off to an interpretation
memory control system in ifg or
potentially
contra directionally there is a
potential for top-down inferences again
predictively as i mentioned earlier
being generated by ifg
so regardless of the story that you
potentially
ground this in uh psts and ifg seem to
be communicating in crucial respects to
generate
basic phrases
uh lastly one final slide here on this
experiment we compared the responses to
when patients saw a picture that matched
the phrase they had and compared that to
when we showed them a picture of a
object which did not match the phrase
that they'd had
and
just a quick just quickly to know here
because this is not too particularly
relevant to the main thrust of the talk
is that we found anterior insular
responses that were greater for phrase
picture matches relative to phrase
picture contrasts
i'm moving on to the second topic
concreteness
the negotiation of concrete and abstract
concepts is a really fundamental
component of everyday life
and in fact if you just think about
random sentences that you speak on the
daily basis and it will almost
definitely have a very broad mixture of
concrete and abstract concepts it's
unavoidable that you have that and in
fact even supposedly concrete concepts
are imbued with an intermixture of
abstract meaning that seems just as
essential to the object's identity as
the concrete
aspect itself so think of something like
lunch you can say lunch was delicious
but delayed
in that sense lunch is an event but it's
also a physical object right lunch can
be three hours two hours one hour but it
could also be tasty or horrific
the same for things like book you can
describe a book as being interesting
and but also heavy you can describe a
book as being sad and but also
hardback or paperback
so even these very supposedly concrete
concepts are imbued with
abstract meaning
and the question for us is how does the
brain negotiate this task of um
conceive of representing concrete and
abstract concepts independently
so there's a general uh
generalization from the neural imaging
literature that there is a greater
engagement for variable systems for
abstract words than for concrete words
but nevertheless the new representation
of concrete in abstract words remains uh
far from resolved uh abstract words just
for a quick consultation abstract words
includes with like time yesterday and
justice whereas concrete words of course
can be perceived through the five senses
so things like things that you can touch
smell taste and so on like table phone
and laptop
so abstract where it's a float to rely
on language uh cortex much more so than
concrete concepts so we gave patients an
rsvp task with orthographic stimuli and
showing them where it's one second
they're weird at the compute words or
abstract words uh or also mid-scale
awareness which i'm not going to talk
about today but mythical words are kind
of interesting uh there was like magic
that have a mixture of both concrete and
abstract meaning
all items were controlled for aoa zip
frequency lens and so on and the task
was for the patients to simply identify
the concreteness so is this where
something that you can touch smell or
taste
so these results are quite preliminary
we only have about 12 or 13 patients i
believe we've done this task but
generally we found greater broadband
gamma activity in ventral temporal
surface where the red indicates greater
70 to 150 hertz and power
during the interpretation of concrete
waves for abstract weights and there is
some preliminary evidence that portions
of ifs or ifg responded greater for
abstract words again subserving language
cortices
moving beyond this we also have
conducted a number of stimulation
sessions in which we took the true
positives during the e-cog task
and a few days later we came back to the
amu and we asked the patients to do the
task again and
and we stimulated during 50
of the trials to see if this causally
disrupted the patient's performance
so for this particular site in here this
patient had right-sided coverage uh
there was electrode mst six and seven
which during clinical stimulation showed
uh narrative reading difficulties
and the e-cog response for this site and
also showed greater bga for concrete
words so without stimulation and inner
words just during the task the patient
scored very well indeed and
but
an average of about 91.5 percent
accuracy but then during stimulation the
patient uh performance dropped
considerably and they performed a chance
for concrete weights and but not not not
for um but after eye words
another patient also
simply same story uh but initially this
electrode showed greater bga responses
for abstract words but not for concrete
words but concreteness itself the
ability to make that judgment was also
knocked out so um
this this fight was also uh
closely attributed to concreteness
ratings
and then lastly another site here where
the patient performed uh 100 accuracy
without
um
abstract words but then for stimulation
they performed a chance for concrete
words
uh lastly i'm going to talk about
coherence so i've talked about
combination putting two words together
um i've talked about concrete versus
abstract words and how they're
represented and the final topic is going
to be about more of the use of these
larger structures and to generate a
general coherent coherence sentence
meaning so um i've mentioned putting two
ways together but what about putting
sentences together right sentences are
often much more common in everyday
conversation than uh two word phrases we
don't usually communicate simply using
two word phrases we usually use multiple
words
and but what happens when you're
constructing a sentence
and the meaning of the sentence is
suddenly uh disrupted to yield a
completely incongruent meaning
so for instance a coherent sentence
would be something like john ate the
delicious cheesecake but an incoherent
sentence would be john 8 the delicious
weekend where there's a kind of category
area there where it says simply a
meaningful
meaningless sense
so
again on this theme the fundamentally
creative and generative nature of
language allows us to refer to a known
entity using phrases we've never
encountered so we know what a banana is
but we may have never heard it described
as an elongated yellow fruit so the
question is how does the brain
figure out make the inference that we're
talking about a very common object using
a collection of words that we've never
heard before we've never i mean i've
never heard of the phrase an elongated
yellow fruit before but i know what it
means it means it means when on it
and so we again using um integrated
recordings we probe this task using a
name and naming to definition
and task where we gave patients
sentences like in rotp style around red
fruit in panel sealer
and versus around red age and the task
of the patient was to define
the
well provide the answer to the
definition so the definition around red
fruit they'd say something like an apple
or a strawberry or something or cherry
or something like that
and but around red age they would be
asked to say nonsense
uh this is 57 patients there's quite a
few years of of research by now a very
generous frontal parietal and temporal
ventricular and mutual temporal coverage
and and so
what we did is we plotted the
activation again in looking at bga
broadband gamma activity across the
passing of defense from weight one two
three four and so on
um and you see activation in ifs ventral
temporal cortex
atl just for the this is um purely the
um activation to sentence comprehension
regardless of referential versus
non-referential uh whether or not the
sensor is congruent or not
but then when we analyze the contrast of
the final word so the congruent versus
incongruent marker was always the final
way in the sentence when we analyze at
the point of the final word we see some
quite interesting responses
so the red coloration here indexes
greater bj for meaningful kind of
congruent and referential sentences so
sentences that refer to something like a
person at the circus who makes you laugh
that's obviously referring to a clown
and in contrast to the non-referential
sentence a person of the circus who
makes you commute which of course
doesn't refer to anything
and we've found greater engagement in
medial parietal cortex hippocampus and
inferior frontal sulcus for the
recruitment to generate the inference of
a meaningful sentence structure
these these regions are much easier to
access using integrated recordings in
particular ifs over ifg ifg is often
implicated a lot in higher order sense
processing in the extracranial world but
using interchangeable recordings we can
show that ifs in particular seems to be
more engaged than ifg in this semantic
task and of course
tracking direct recordings from medial
parietal cortex is very difficult indeed
using uh
say say meg
iag is really the only way that you can
probe this activity
so this is just plotting the traces for
npc electrodes you can see that the
effect begins around 250 milliseconds
and lasts until just before the point of
articulation and i've also plotted on
the bottom right of the figure you can
see the traces for uh before the onset
of the final word and also during
patient articulation so the effect does
seem to be a uniquely semantic effect it
seems to be an effect driven by meaning
and not driven by articulation planning
or pre-final word differences even of
course to the same sense just to
kind of validate this effect
and so the effect on npc and ifs seems
to be as i mentioned a meaningful
effective of meaning
we also plot the differences between
left and right hemisphere here just to
show that the effect is indeed specific
to language dominant left hemisphere and
it's it's not an effective right
hemisphere
so we also showed this effect in vm pfc
ventromedial prefrontal cortex which has
also been implicated in the last five or
six years in forms of high road
combination and coherence and so we show
that here again a slightly later effect
the effector rises around 800
milliseconds for vmpsc so quite later
than hippocampus ifs on npc but
nevertheless the effect is there and you
can think of all sorts of potential
explanations for why the effect is later
there
but again it seems to be unique to
language stone and hemisphere
this is plotting the effects in
hippocampus so we took the electrodes
that were placed uh directly solely
within hippocampus proper and the
electrodes that were placed
in neighboring parahebric parahibicampal
gyrus using the human connectedness
project postulation map and we plot here
the um traces for hippocampal theta
power and contrast it with power
hippocampal gyrus ega responses and you
can see that there's a kind of a nice
pickup effect where you have early uh
roughly and 400 windowy effects in uh
hippocampal theta being immediately
followed by power hippocampal
gyrus vga effects
uh as you can see from the spectrograms
the effect is extremely clear and both
for low frequencies and hippocampus and
in higher frequencies for parahypic
ample gyrus
i've plotted a couple of um
example electrodes in panel b and then
in panel c we again looked at functional
connectivity between our regions of
interest and we showed that between npc
and hippocampus
the
functional connectivity between these
two regions for sentences that were
meaningless or incongruent actually
dropped there was a significant drop out
in connectivity during the meaningless
sentences so the
effect seems to be present not simply in
the local responses in these discrete
regions of interest but it also seems to
be reflected in the communication the
inter-areal communication between the
reasons that we've identified as being
sensitive to these aspects of higher
order linguistic meaning
and then we also did a separate analysis
where we took all of the sentences that
were meaningless so i mentioned the
example earlier and a person at the
circus who makes you commute now that's
obviously a non-referential sentence but
it's still kind of meaningful right
and there could be a person at the
circus who makes you commute right it's
possible and that just doesn't happen to
be but a bunch of our sentences were
either meaningful in that sense a
meaningful story in that sense with a
kind of what we call the weak violation
so there a weak violation in our terms
simply means that
it's a coherent semantic concept concept
you can construct the concept it just
doesn't happen to refer to any human
being on the other hand we have we have
sentences in our uh stimuli set like um
a place where oceans shop
where there's a real semantic kind of
category error
you know it's like trying to describe a
tiger as a financial institution it's
just completely completely meaningless
whereas the crown example is is
non-referential it doesn't refer but
it's still meaningful you can construct
a meaningful english sentence so what we
did is we we we trusted the weak with
the strong violation non-coherent uh
sentences and we put their responses
here again looking at bj and there was a
pretty clear effect in um
triangularis and middle temporal gyrus
for a week
as opposed to strong violations so in
other words where there was semantic
coherence
then you find creative bga in ifg and
mtg
now what's interesting about this
analysis is that both of the sentences
that we can trust in this analysis were
non-referential they were they didn't
actually successfully define anything
right they were completely non-defining
sentences but half of the sentences were
kind of semantically coherent on the
other half were semantically incoherent
so this is a nice way of kind of
tapping into
a pure
language specific semantic coherence
independent of the task so this is not
related of course to
success versus
unsuccessful because both of these
sentences were unsuccessful in the task
right neither of the sentences referred
and then we also did a separate analysis
where we um
looked at the point of the sentence in
which the answer became obvious so for
some sentences the answer was not
obvious until the final word but then
other sentences uh the answer was
obvious by about halfway through the
sentence and again we kind of showed
that the regions that were sensitive the
reasons have to do the reasons i had to
do more work at the final width so the
limited narrowing sensors also
overlapped with the areas we found for
the coherent versus uh incoherent
analysis
so npc and ifs and so on so it seems as
if this process this kind of narrowing
process of narrowing down the set of
possible um answers to kind of you know
reducing the hypothesis space seems to
be coded by the same regions
again isolating one of the reasons from
this area was psts so psts uniquely
responded for the narrowing analysis
that i just showed you on the last slide
but it wasn't if you recall it also
wasn't responsive to the broader
referential basis non-referential
analysis so what's going on here well
this seems to suggest that psts as i
showed at the beginning of this talk
when i talked about combination psts
seems to code for uh semantic
integration it cares about integrating
different aspects of linguistic meaning
but it doesn't care too much about
things like coherence which is subserved
by frontal and parietal regions
and you can see example our traces here
where there's no effect of referential
risk of non-referential the psjs doesn't
care if the sentence is defining an
object or not but it does care if the
sentence is um
reducing the hypothesis space so
integrating semantic
information in a meaningful way
so finally just to kind of generate a
very specific model for this uh this
model for linguistic reference was
derived purely from our own experiment
here so i'm putting aside all the other
regions that we know and care about like
midfielder from gyrus and atl and i've
just focused on the regions that we can
motivate using this particular analysis
so you can see that npc ifs and vmpfc
care about reference and
inferential memory and attention and so
on whereas the regions that care about
types systematic types are subserved by
lateral temporal and frontal areas and
this follows kind of standard model and
semantics and defining linguistic
meaning in terms of types individual
tokens so multiple copies of types and
then the actual reference
and so again just to summarize
combination seem to be subserved by a
mosaic like response in psds
concreteness by medial fractal temporal
and coherence by this network that i've
just shown off parietal ifs and
hippocampus
and these independent directions for
exploring language reveal how the brain
processes some of the most crucial
aspects of meaning necessary for worldly
engagements and i'd like to thank you
for listening and thank you to my fellow
lab members
you